why be normal when you can be the best
camera is a 35 year old where everybody
thought I was in a wheelchair and what
happened
the lion is still alive
I don't know how much I've lived I just
want to enjoy my moment I don't want to
have a headache
I want to go into something but I go
into something 200 percent and
and I want to enjoy it because I know
when I stop I will miss all of those
things I will miss all everything around
the football what is happening
I will miss the the smell of the grass I
will miss the the vibration from the
stadiums when it's full obviously I will
miss the big stage of of the stadiums so
I just want to enjoy my moment sometimes
you're right sometimes you're wrong at
least you're being yourself we all do
mistakes
we learn from the mistakes but we will
still do mistakes
and being perfect what is being perfect
you build up something that doesn't
exist for me Perfection is being
yourself
and I am being myself people like it or
not
I don't care as long as I'm being myself
I try to surround myself with positive
energy
uh Positive Vibes and
push myself to
to be positive to be open-minded and it
was a new day is a new day you learn
every day you learn something new and
and discover something new so and I try
to to enter everything you know with a
positive mindset obviously in my
profession I go in for the kill to
become better and
to improve myself and
and to challenge myself to be a better
Zlatan every day
I think the mental part is 50 in
everything we do either if you play
football or whatever you work with
because if you're not ready mentally
doesn't matter how big talent you have
or
how prepared you are because if you're
not prepared mentally and the ready man
in with the mental part then then it's
very difficult because
I think the confidence
comes from the mental part I know if I'm
really mentally then the rest I have no
problems because I know what I'm able to
do and and we're all professionals we
all get judged for what we do
our professional work is to play
football
in my world I get judged after every
last training and every last game I do
is part of the game if you come up among
lions
you should expect to get attacked by the
Lions is normal because if you're a cat
you will run away but if you're a lion
you will stay among the other Lions
that's my world that's where I come from
because I believe in things I believe I
can make a difference or
or make noise and some things you do
from your heart some things you do from
from the brain and there is a risk in
everything you do you never know how it
goes
but I think if you do it in a proper way
and it feels real natural if you fail or
not I think you should not be afraid of
risking something you have to
have the courage to do it and if I
believe in something I will do 200 to to
make it successful
I say what I think I say what I believe
in
afterwards
maybe it doesn't
suit everybody
but I'm just being myself and
I don't change for nobody or or
something I'm I've been myself since day
one and I said to myself I will not
change for
for nobody or however successful I I
will become I will not change I will be
myself I mean I am the one and only no
I'm very simple I need my training I
need my family to be happy because if I
know they're happy I can focus on my
main thing and that's the football so I
think many are disappointed that I am
like that because they were expecting
more crazy things to happen around me
people expecting the negative things
because I think that sells more
they're not looking the other side of
the coin where you work hard you do the
sacrifice you do the professional
because that's too clean they want to
see the dirty thing after 20 years in
Europe playing for the best clubs in the
world best with best players in the
world I've been winning so much I think
what I collected it's time to move to a
different continent I think you say so
move over to us
try the MLS
for me there was no question about it
Galaxy was the team and I choose them so
they didn't need to choose me I chose
them and I come
to do exactly what I've been doing the
last 20 23 years winning because I feel
it's in my DNA wherever I come I won and
I will still do it so I'm coming to win
I'm coming to help and make it better I
don't like
to be among many where everybody says
he's just like everybody else no no I go
out from that group where they Point
their finger and say this guy is
different he can do different things
and that is what I work hard for I want
to be as complete as possible and be
able to do it
better than other ones because we play
soccer yeah it's Collective yes but in
the end it's survival mode because being
among many it means that another person
can do your job and when I enter in a
field I say to myself nobody else can do
what I do nobody can do my job
I'm a little bit old school and from the
new school because new school I feel you
get attention very fast for doing very
little before you needed to do more to
get a little attention and my family
they don't live in my in my shadow in my
shade they are more important than my
profession my kids is bigger than than
my football they are important
so wherever I go where is their area
let's say in their training I'm just a
father I'm not a football player I am
even discreet coming there I don't want
people to to even see me because it's
their area they are the stores in that
environment that is important for me the
kids for me is the future they're the
ones that follow you they're the ones
that take you as an example
and I think it's important to give back
and all the all the love you get in the
stadium all the energy you get in the
stadium the adrenaline it's like I said
it's 50 in the that goes in the head and
you you just want to give back and if I
cannot give it back on the field I try
to give a outside the field so but we
shouldn't also forget that I'm a human
being just like everybody else I have
feelings I have
emotional just like everybody else but I
try to give back as much as possible in
a natural way I don't try to build up an
image that
somebody likes but it's not being myself
I need to be myself so if I'm not myself
I don't feel comfortable
for me the attention is not important
you can see an example is the social
media and I'm not even active on that
because I don't leave a social media
life like many
players out there live and they want
this attention and they need it my
attention is the way I perform
and I know how I can perform and what I
need to perform I'm the best at what I
what I'm able to do so all the other
things around this is not important
because who would recognize you if you
were not the football player nobody so
it's not important for me I was not born
in this world to to become friend with
the whole world that people know me
because I'm a football player people
don't know me because
I am a person that did whatever I did
outside the field and I push it even
more like I said whatever the the limit
was I have no limits I want I wanted to
be as much as possible just to make
noise and in a difference
but in a positive way so that for me is
very important but I've worked hard for
it that is nothing that came on a red
carpet and and that will be my legacy